WOULD HAVE CELEBRATED MASS THIS
WEEKEND.
>> Tucker: HORRIFYING,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT.
WELL, THE FIRE YOU HAVE BEEN
WATCHING IS IN SOME WAYS
METAPHOR.
THE BROADER DECLINE OF
CHRISTIANITY IN EUROPE.
THE DECLINE HAS BEEN'S SWIFT
WITH CONSEQUENCES.
MARK STEYN STARTING THIS
QUESTION 40 YEARS AND WE ARE
GLAD TO HAVE HIM WITH US
TONIGHT, MARK THANK YOU FOR
COMING ON.
THERE IS ONE THAT I CANNOT GET
OUT OF MY MIND, WE HAVEN'T BUILT
ANYTHING LIKE NOTRE DAME
CATHEDRAL IN THE WEST IN SO
LONG.
WE DON'T BUILD THINGS THAT ARE
BEAUTIFUL ANYMORE.
ONLY BY DESIGN.
WILL THERE EVER BE ANYTHING LIKE
THAT EVER AGAIN?
>> Mark: I THINK WE HAVE LOST
THE KNACK.
NOTRE DAME IS ABOUT A TEN MINUTE
WALK FROM THE POMPIDOU CENTER
NAME FOR THE LATE POMPIDOU AND
THAT IS ONE OF THE DASH ALMOST
LIKE ANY MODERN BUILDING IN
PARIS, THAT IS ONE OF THE
UGLIEST THINGS YOU'VE EVER SEEN.
AND WHEN YOU GO BACK EIGHT AND A
HALF CENTURIES TO THE TIME WHEN
THIS BUILDING BEGAN
CONSTRUCTION, IT TOOK A CENTURY
FOR THE FIRST PART OF IT TO BE
COMPLETED.
THE MAN WHO SET TO WORK ON THIS
NEW THEY WOULD NOT SEE IT
FINISHED IN THEIR LIFETIME.
BUT THEIR SENSE OF A
TRANSCENDENT MEANING TO LIFE WAS
SO STRONG, THAT THE IDEA OF
BUILDING THE MOST BEAUTIFUL
BUILDING TO THE GLORY OF GOD,
THEY TOOK NATURALLY IN A WAY
THAT WE DON'T ANYMORE.
>> Tucker: WELL, AND THAT, OF
COURSE, THE REASON THEY BUILT
BUILDINGS LIKE NOTRE DAME AND
THE FIRST PLACE.
NOT JUST FOR THE AMUSEMENT BUT
TO GLORIFY GOD.
THIS IS NOT, LET'S BE CLEAR, NOT
SPECULATING THAT BECAUSE OF THE
FIRE, YOU KNOW, IT HAPPENED AS
CHRIS GALLAGHER
TRRIS GALLAGHER
TRACS GALLAGHER
TRACE GALLAGHER, HOLY WEEK AND
IT IS NOT THE ONLY CHURCH THAT
HAS CAUSED CAUGHT FIRE IN FRANC.
IF YOU DESECRATION'S OF CHURCHES
BUT GIVE US A SKILL OF WHAT'S
BEEN HAPPENING?
>> Mark: IN RETREAT IN EUROPE,
AND IN FRANCE PARTICULARLY COME
UP FRANCE HAS QUITE AN
AGGRESSIVE BELIEF IN SECULARISM
AND ACCORDING TO SOME POLLS, THE
FRENCH OR EVEN BY THE STANDARDSO
FRENCH OR EVEN BY THE STANDARDSF
THE MOLTEN WEST WORLD TO COME
MOST GODLESS PEOPLE IN THAT
SENSE.
THREE YEARS AGO AND THAT
TERRIBLE SUMMER THAT BEGAN WITH
THE KNEES TRUCK KILLINGS.
THE ENTIRE FRENCH WAS
UNRAVELING, I WENT TO THE
CATHEDRAL FOR THE PARAMOUNT, THE
FRENCH PRIEST WHO HAD HIS THROAT
CUT AT MASS.
AND THEN THE BASILICA OF
SAINT-DENIS', AND THE NORTH OF
PARIS WHERE THE FRENCH KINGS OF
BURIED.
AND BASICALLY A CHRISTIAN MUSEUM
AND THE HEART OF WHAT IS NOW A
MUSLIM SUBURBAN IN EFFECT.
THERE IS NO SENSE OF
CHRISTIANITY OUTSIDE OF THE
WALLS OF THAT CATHEDRAL.
IT WAS AFTER THAT THAT I WENT TO
NOTRE DAME BECAUSE YOU DO HAVE
THE SENSE THAT A LIVING,
BREATHING FAITH IS JUST BECOMING
ACTUALLY COME A MUSEUM.
AN ART GALLERY.
A STORAGE FACILITY.
AND THE FRENCH WHO WERE ON THE
STREETS OF PARIS, THIS EVENING.
THEY ARE NOT MORNING JUST
HISTORY OR ARCHITECTURAL ART OR
CULTURAL.
THEY ARE MOURNING SOMETHING
ELSE.
BUT WHAT THAT SOMETHING ELSE
POST-CHRISTIAN FRANCE CAN'T
QUITE IDENTIFY IT.
THAT IS REALLY THE CONUNDRUM.
WHEN HE SAYS WE WILL REBUILD IT,
FOR WHAT?
WHEN PEOPLE TALK ABOUT THE HEART
OF FRANCE HAS DIED?
WHAT IS IN THE SOUL OF FRANCE?
WHAT IS THIS?
IS IT JUST THE BUILDING OR
SOMETHING MORE.
>> Tucker: AND SO SPECIFICALLY
AS YOU WELL KNOW, IT WAS
DESANCTIFIED, D CHRISTIANIZED
DURING THE FRENCH REVOLUTION FOR
A TIME AND WAS MADE A SECULAR
TEMPLE, BUT THEN IMMEDIATELY
REVERTED TO WHAT IT ALWAYS WAS,
WHICH WAS A CHRISTIAN HOLY
PLACE.
DO YOU THINK THERE IS ANY HOPE
IN SOMETHING LIKE THAT WILL
HAPPEN AGAIN IN FRANCE?
>> Mark: YOU NEVER KNOW HOW
THESE THINGS WILL GO.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THE HUNCHBACK OF
NOTRE DAME, THE NOVEL, QUITE A
LOT TO RESTORE THE IMPORTANCE OF
NOTRE DAME IN THE MINDS OF THE
FRENCH PEOPLE.
BUT MICHELLE WELL BACK A
CONTROVERSIAL NOTABLE LIST, A
SUMMATION WHICH POSES THAT
FRANCE ELECTS A MUSLIM PRESIDEN
PRESIDENT.
AND HE KNOWS THE SINGLE
CHARACTER KNOWS THIS WILL MEAN
SOMETHING.
AND HE ACTUALLY MAKES A
CONSCIOUS EFFORT TO TRY TO
RECOVER HIS LOST CATHOLIC FAITH.
AND THOSE ARE THE KIND OF
PILGRIMAGE, AND HE HAS MOVED BY
THE MUSIC.
HE IS MOVED BY THE RITUAL.
BUT HE CAN'T QUITE MAKE THE
FINAL STEP AND RECONNECT WITH
GOD AND THE CATHOLIC FAITH.
AND THAT SEEN IN THAT BOOK IS IN
A CERTAIN SENSE THE QUESTION
RAISED BY THIS FIRE TONIGHT.
IS IT A HOLE IN THE SOUL OR A
MISSING BUILDING BURNED TO THE
GROUND?
>> Tucker: HAS IT MADE IT A